6 41 on a friday morning now it's time
for our nacho big game grub showdown all
right earlier we showed you soul belly
barbecues easy to make nacho dish now
it's distilling remedy's turn
recipe number three for the big game and
chef jeff you're doing something first
of all it's my favorite
nachos you can not have a football game
without nachos i agree but this has got
a little like spin on spin on it yeah
kind of keep it with that whole tailgate
barbecue thing yeah with the pulled pork
the barbecue sauce but we did a little
spin on like a pepper jack queso
sauce kind of give it a little bit of a
spicy kick
it up a little bit show me the queso
because this is something i would say
yeah i mean you totally can buy it 100
you can buy your normal queso sauce
you can add diced tomatoes uh
diced jalapenos whatever whatever flavor
profile you really want to go for with
me i loaded it up with a bunch of cream
cheese jalapenos
pepper jack cheese and you know stuff
like that we deep fry these and then we
toss them in a little bit of taco
seasoning we make ours which you can
totally buy it oh it's just a mix of
paprika chili powder cumin and
granulated garlic awesome
so i'd be pretty much equivalent to like
the store market taco tv and this is up
to you how much you want to put on i
love cheese sauce so i'm gonna go a
little bit heavy you know we're not
making soup but it's gonna be close too
once you're done with that you're gonna
take your pulled pork i like to hand
shred mine you can do it you know you
can chop it hand shred it whatever you
guys you know want to do this is just
giving you a nice base they have a
pre-made packet um i even uh has
barbecue sauce in it you know take it
home put it in a saute pan or a stockpot
just let it go nice and i know what do
we garnish this way i keep it very
simple because we want to taste that
pork in that cheese sauce and i like to
finish it with a little bit more cheese
because why not i'm guessing the key is
that you have to get cheese on every
every chip every chip correct you want
every chip that tastes the same awesome
elevated matches
distilling remedy and of course you
could always get all of this and more
absolutely yeah you can come get it at
any one of our distilled remedies
locations especially check out our new
distill uh on rainbow
beautiful bar brand new kitchen so come
check us out and uh some really good
food too all right i'm digging in
that's a big bite yeah that's a perfect
bite